[Música]
bom eu vou contar hoje pra vocês é uma
história sobre um equipamento que está
sendo construído em campinas como foi
mencionado que hoje está entre os
equipamentos mais sofisticados que está
sendo construído no mundo e que ele o
equipamento para examinar exatamente
nessa escala do desenho que está aí que
a escala dos atos
então antes de eu chegar no equipamento
e essa história que vou contar pra vocês
envolve mais ou menos mais de 30 anos de
várias pessoas que são muitos jogadores
brasileiros como eu certo aqui todo esse
projeto há quase nove anos desse novo
acelerador mas o que estão vendo aí que
hoje a gente toma com uma coisa quase
óbvia que a gente tudo nas escolas e
falei e demorou séculos para se
transformar em realidade que é o que a
gente chama de hipóteses e atômica o que
toda a matéria que a gente conhece nessa
nossa escala que é composta de atos
certo isso permite que você entenda como
funciona desde o nosso corpo humano até
com os materiais funcionam simplesmente
utilizando essa ideia ilustra essa ideia
é com um exemplo que todo mundo vai
conseguir facilmente identificar que é a
diferença entre o diamante certo e todo
mundo deve talvez boa parte das pessoas
o time está utilizando aí é um anel de
diamante grafite na ponta de um lápis
eu tinha pedido pra minha esposa ela
achou que não era aconselhável trazer o
anel dela aqui então eu desistir da
idéia de mostrar alguma coisa mas tanto
diamante quanto o a ponta de um lápis
eles são com os materiais distintos é
com valores distintos e propriedades
distintas mas ambos são compostos
somente pelo mesmo tipo de ato carbono
certo que também está no nosso corpo em
várias é formas mas nesse caso em
particular é só o átomo de carbono e por
que então que você se tem o mesmo tipo
de átomo compondo estes dois materiais
eles são tão distintos porque não basta
saber os átomos que compõem o material
mas é importante também saber como eles
estão é ligados no espaço com a
estrutura que esses átomos estão
ocupando certo
isso você precisa de algum tipo de
ferramenta como eu posso enxergar e
entender essas perguntas que eu estou
colocando pra vocês e que não são fundas
tão fundamentais para a gente entender a
matéria que é quais são os átomos que
compõem o material mas além disso qual é
a distribuição ea estrutura deles no
espaço ou seja como ele se liga então a
gente sai de ferramentas
a gente está acostumado é de que para
responder perguntas a gente utiliza como
meio de ferramentas se eu vou querer
olhar alguma coisa que é pequeno uma
lupa e assim vai ser então vamos ver
como é que os físicos fazem para
enxergar entre aspas
essas coisas que são tão pequenas eles
fazem uma coisa que está ilustrada nesse
desenho aí que é jogar algo na matéria
e esse algo pode ser variado vocês hoje
estão enxergando enxergando todo mundo
porque eu tenho uma fonte de luz que
bate em mim e chega no detector
extremamente é desenvolvido que o olho
de vocês
certo e tem um processador que é o
cérebro que processa imagens mas você
precisa que eu jogasse isso em mim pra
chegar em vocês pra vocês aprenderem
sobre mim e é isso que a gente faz
comumente para aprender sobre a matéria
a gente joga coisas nela e essas coisas
podem ser a luz como que a gente chama
de radiação eletromagnética ela só um
pedacinho da radiação eletromagnética
mas ela podem ser partículas como a
gente fala podem celebra os nêutrons
então essa idéia básica é que os físicos
vem utilizando há muito tempo para
investigar a estrutura da matéria muito
bem para isso eu preciso de ferramentas
certo
a luz que agentes estão utilizando pra
enxergar ela não tem propriedades
apropriadas para eu estudar algo na
escala dos atos
então como eu posso estudar isso nessa
escala
e aí precisou aí tem um conjunto de
vários personagens numa história que
demorou mais de um século e um deles
primeiro é esse senhor barbudo aí de
cima quebrou ontem que em 1900 1895 ele
descobriu algo que ele nem sabia o que
era e que chamou de raio x e todos vocês
sabem a importância do raio x na verdade
foi uma das descobertas que mais
rapidamente
teve aplicação uma das aplicações de
imediato foi inclusive com a esposa dele
uma das primeiras imagens que ele fez
foi pedir para a esposa dele colocar a
mão ela estava com um anel ea gente
enxerga aí a mão do da esposa do
rodrigão com o anel
imediatamente ela teve aplicação em
medicina mas ele chamou de raio x que
não tinha a menor idéia do que era
aquilo
certo que coisa é essa que a princípio a
travessa matéria certo e as pessoas não
tinha idéia do que é e não sabiam que
ela era algo parecido com essa luz que
vocês estão vendo não se sabia isso
ainda
aí o rapaz o senhor que está lá bigodudo
meio carequinha no meio ele achava aqui
é essa esse raio x era de fato o que a
gente chama de ondas eletromagnéticas
só que com a outra é a freqüência de
oscilação e falou como eu posso tentar
provar isso daí
e ele imaginou bom se esse cumprimento
de oscilação dessa onda foi parecido com
a distância dos átomos
eu vou perceber ao jogar esse raio x um
determinado material
o efeito dessa interação isso vai
aparecer e foi exatamente isso que ele
fez certo
ele fez um experimento parecido com o
que está nesse desenho onde ele tinha
uma fonte de raio x ele tinha um cristal
ele jogou e ele percebeu que esse raio x
foi espalhado em direções muito
características específicas o que
indicavam que aquilo era uma onda
eletromagnética o pai filho do desenho
que está embaixo que são os blogs
ele imediatamente veja que as datas são
parecidas eles imediatamente perceberam
que aquilo que o lauro estava usando
para provar que a onda eletromagnética
eles podiam usar para descobrir aonde os
atos estão no espaço
e pela primeira vez na história a gente
tinha agora uma ferramenta que conseguia
dizer como os átomos se organizava no
espaço e eles fizeram esse experimento a
primeira vez com salzinho de cozinha foi
a primeira estrutura que nós seres
humanos descobrimos utilizando um raio-x
aonde que tacada a composição ea onde
eles estão distribuídos no espaço
diamante que eu coloquei a imagem lá no
começo eles na seqüência um ano depois
foram os primeiros a dizer qualquer a
estrutura do diamante agora a gente
sabia quais eram como os átomos estavam
organizados no espaço
isso teve um impacto tão importante
certo que hoje há a imagem de cima do
que estão olhando que são todos
moléculas ligadas à vida biologia o dna
certo a dupla hélice do outro lado
proteínas do outro lado a estrutura de
vírus eles utilizam raios x para saber
essa estrutura não vejo que é uma das
descobertas mais importantes que a
humanidade fez que foi a estrutura do
dna depender dessas invenções dessas
descobertas e desse desenvolvimento para
poder é você saber qual que é aonde
assim a chave de certa forma da vida que
a estrutura do dna muito bem continuando
a nossa história
os times continuaram preocupados em a
estrutura não somente de como a
organização dos átomos era mas qual é a
estrutura interna do próprio ato certo o
que é o ato mato é de fato algo
indivisível átomo tem uma estrutura
interna do que é composta essa estrutura
interna e você precisava de algo além de
raio x por exemplo
nesse caso esse senhor aqui que é o luta
for do lado de um colaborador dele que o
gere todo mundo já deve ter ouvido falar
no detector gaga
esse é o cara que inventou detector eles
estavam justamente por se perguntando na
época qual que é a estrutura dentro de
um ato certo e para isso eles utilizaram
essa mesma idéia de jogar coisas na
matéria
só que no caso eles utilizaram que a
gente chamava de uma fonte radioativo
foi mencionado que a gente fez explosões
nucleares e isso vai aparecer
geologicamente é como uma marca nossa na
terra ea gente só avançou nessa parte
nuclear porque essas pessoas começaram a
utilizar essas técnicas para entender a
estrutura da matéria então ele
ele utilizou essas fontes radioativas
jogou na matéria e descobriu que o ato
era composto de um núcleo onde toda a
carga positiva estava concentrada e no
entorno tinha os elétrons ele foi o
primeiro que agora desvendou o qual
seria essa real estrutura
o ato só que ele mesmo percebeu que para
continuar entendendo do que é por
exemplo o núcleo composto que tem dentro
do núcleo etc para seguir esse caminho
de desvendar a estrutura da matéria as
fontes naturais radioativas que ele
tinha à disposição não seriam
suficientes
ele precisava de fontes com maior
energia certo é uma alternativa seria o
que muitas pessoas na época utilizava
inclusive um físico brasileiro talvez
esse tenha ouvido falar o cesar lattes
que utilizou muitos chamados raios
cósmicos que tinham partículas de alta
energia mas ele queria algo mais
controlável isso que ele é propunha era
então a construção de aceleradores de
partículas para você poder acelerar
essas partículas de forma controlada
cada vez com maior energia pra você
poderia incidir na matéria e aprender
sobre a estrutura interna e é isso que
os físicos vem fazendo desde 1930
aqui tem uma foto é com rússia forte que
aquele que eu acabei de falar no meio
com dois dos seus alunos que foram os
primeiros que quebraram o núcleo certo
utilizando um acelerador de partículas
em baixo muitos de vocês devem ter
ouvido falar acompanhado nas notícias o
grande acelerador é na suíça que
atravessa a suíça ea frança que
descobriu recentemente a chamada é o
bóson de rics então você vê que houve um
contínuo avanço para energias mais altas
um conseqüente entendimento cada vez
mais a estrutura interna da matéria
voltando agora onde o brasil vai entrar
nessa história
eu vou agora mostrar que lá pelo final
da década de 40
os físicos é que estavam utilizando
aceleradores e aí tem uma cena do
pequenininho na foto em preto e branco a
vocês estão vendo eles observarão uma
uma luz que saía desse acelerador deles
inicialmente eles acharam que isso era
um defeito no acelerador mas depois eles
perceberam que isso era uma coisa que
havia sido prevista ligado ao fato de
que cargas quando são aceleradas e
quando você tem as cargas no acelerador
elas são aceleradas como a gente está
andando de carro está acelerado
ela
a emitir radiação ou luz é a radiação
eletromagnética mãe no espectro amplo de
freqüência é a luz que a gente está a
usar chamando sempre essa lusa que
visível do espectro uma parte pequena
mas eles é perceberam que eles tinham
observado pela primeira vez essa luz que
a gente chama hoje de luz sinto muito
bem
aí os físicos pediram permissão para os
físicos de partículas que estavam
construindo seus aliás aceleradores pra
corrigir coisas
eles pediram licença ou permissão para
esses físicos de partículas pra eles e
vamos assim abrir um buraco no
acelerador desse pessoal para poder
extrair essa radiação simples e ao fazer
isso eles começaram a utilizar essa
radiação síncrotron que no fundo tinha
raio-x certo para investigar a matéria
isso se mostrou tão potente tão
importante que a partir dos anos 80 você
começa a ter a construção de
aceleradores dedicados por isso que a
setinha diverge porque eles são parte da
mesma família mas ela divergem para a
construção de aceleradores dedicados
para a extração dessa luz que eu já vou
falar agora a partir de agora mais sobre
ela e hoje em dia você tem é dezenas
desses cinco anos pelo mundo
certo e é uma busca contínua da mesma
maneira que os riscos de partícula
constrói aceleradores cada vez com maior
energia para poder investigar a
estrutura mais interna da matéria o que
os físicos ou cientistas que utilizam
essa radiação síncrotron buscam é o que
a gente chama de cada vez maior brilho
dessas máquinas e eles ilustram com esse
desenho que está aí com essa imagem que
compara uma lanterna com isso daqui que
é um ponteiro laser
se a luz acabar aqui alguém tiver uma
lanterna
vai ser uma pessoa muito mais útil para
ser seguida do que eu estou com essa
ponteira laser certo porque porque a
lanterna ela tem uma área grande e
abertura angular dessa luz é grande é
bom para iluminar objetos grandes
espaços grandes ela feita pra isso
quando a gente vai fazer um exame de
raio x no hospital
é isso que você quer sequer poder
iluminar uma parte grande do seu corpo
mas veja se eu quero estudar algo na
escala dos átomos certo
a maior parte dessa luz gerada vai se
perder não vai bater naquela região
ela não é eficiente a tela tem baixo
brilho é muito melhor algo parecido com
uma ponteira laser certo
e justamente essas máquinas elas geram
um raio x de alto brilho certo
diferentemente do equipamento que você
tem no hospital e o que você quer cada
vez construir aceleradores que tem o
brilho cada vez mais alto para poder
fazer experimentos numa escala que
ninguém consegue ou com uma velocidade
que ninguém consegue e poder explorar
situações que hoje são impossíveis de
serem medidas
esse crescimento é um crescimento
exponencial esse gráfico aí
apesar de ele estar numa reta é um
gráfico logaritmo então esse crescimento
tem sido exponencial longo dos anos
passando por diferentes gerações 1ª 2ª e
3ª e esses equipamentos mudaram
completamente o estudo da matéria
certo hoje eles são os equipamentos mais
sofisticados que você tem preço da
matéria e devido a isso todos os países
têm construído mais cinco tons você vê
que tem uma distribuição enorme dele
pelo globo certo devido à sua
importância e o brasil foi pioneiro no
hemisfério sul
certo se você for olhar aqui tem um
monte de de aceleradores distribuídos
pelo hemisfério norte e só tem duas
bandeirinhas ou pontinhos no hemisfério
sul e um na austrália e no brasil
só que o brasil foi pioneiro construir o
primeiro e esse é o foi o sonho de
algumas pessoas no início da década de
80 que acreditou que o brasil era capaz
de construir um equipamento como esse
certo a gente não tinha gente a gente
não tinha conhecimento ea gente não
tinha nem dinheiro para construir isso
aí
mas essas pessoas não se importaram com
nenhuma dessas dificuldades e fizeram
uma coisa muito importante que hoje é a
gente tá eu vou contar pra vocês daqui a
pouco como a gente está se beneficiando
disso foi treinar pessoas
hoje alguém falou na palestra de manhã
que a tecnologia é importante mas mais
importante do que tecnologia gente isso
é verdade e é exatamente isso que esse
projeto é um projeto sobre pessoas
que é tiveram a coragem de decidir que
no brasil era possível construir algo
sofisticado como esse mesmo que
praticamente todo mundo achava que não
era possível
demorou dez anos certo eles de 87 e 97
contrato contratar os jovens graduados
jovens engenheiros físicos cento e
construir e colocar para funcionar esse
acelerador se pedro que fica em campinas
e que até hoje está operando hoje ele
recebe mais de mil pessoas das mais
variadas áreas físicos químicos médicos
biólogos geólogos geofísicos que vão
fazer os seus experimentos em
laboratório aberto em qualquer
pesquisador do brasil pode utilizar é só
submeteu a proposta e tentar utilizá lá
muito bem mas aonde o mundo tá do ponto
de vista de perguntas a gente avançou
muito certo quando eu contei comecei uma
história lá é no início do século
passado nós construímos uma série de
ferramentas e aprendemos um monte sobre
a estrutura da matéria
certo do que nós somos feitos do que o
mundo é feito na verdade do que o
universo inteiro efeito mas as perguntas
ea gente hoje um conjunto de palestras
que abordam questões importantes ligadas
à nutrição ea energias alternativas à
saúde a compreensão do cérebro e tetra
elas envolvem sistemas que você quer
mais do que só enxergar a estrutura
atômica de um determinada região de
sistema
esse sistema eu estou mostrando aqui uma
bateria a bateria poderia ser a bateria
dos carros que a gente lê no jornal que
os países estão todos migrando pra ter
carros elétricos que nos próximos 15
anos 10 anos 20 anos se está eliminando
combustíveis fósseis ou até motores a
combustão
você precisa de melhores baterias ou
essas daqui como essas nos celulares
certo em última instância essa bateria
tem íons de lítio nas baterias de lítio
são hoje as mais utilizadas
você tem o sítio certo que tem que tá
estruturados e nano partículas que
formam várias regiões interfaces e você
quer enxergar todo esse conjunto nessa
escala ou cérebro como já foi mencionado
que é uma das estruturas mais complexas
que a gente tem e que você tem que desde
a escala da vacina
esses da interação é onde você tem
moléculas que são trocadas entre
neurônios até os neurônios in se
transportam ios até à organização desses
neurônios como enxergar essas coisas
certas e para isso você precisa de novos
equipamentos e é isso que o brasil está
construindo hoje aqui e que de certa
forma é um é um dos projetos mais
avançados do mundo
então se vocês lembram aquele meu
gráfica tinha primeira segunda terceira
geração aonde o mundo está hoje o mundo
está hoje aonde o brasil está liderando
que na quarta geração desde 2012 o
brasil começou a crescer em 2009 foi o
início do projeto em 2012
você a gente começou de fato construir
nessa nova geração que o brasil está
construindo um novo acelerador que vai
ter um dos brilhos mais é maiores do
mundo certo ele na verdade está sendo
construído para quando entrar em
operação que o maior brilho do mundo e
que vai permitir que você faz
experimentos que não é que o brasil
nunca fez alguns experimentos que no
mundo nunca foram feitos
a gente está construindo estações de
trabalho para fazer tomografia de
células onde você vai poder enxergar
células ea gente vai ter resolução
suficiente para entender a estrutura do
dna enrolado dentro do núcleo certo esse
é o tipo de experimento que a gente está
pensando em fazer é nos filhos ea gente
está desenvolvendo com é projeto 100%
brasileiro com tecnologia brasileira
envolvendo empresas brasileiras que era
impossível muitos falavam que a gente
não teria empresas brasileiras capazes
de fornecer isso essa é uma imagem dele
a não é 100% atual está em construção a
gente espera ter o primeiro fez que a
gente fala no ano que vem e todas as
áreas do conhecimento vão se beneficiar
diferentemente dos aceleradores que foca
na estrutura de partículas um acelerador
cinquentão ele gera esse raio x ultra
brilhante que pode beneficiar qualquer
área do conhecimento principalmente no
mundo como hoje onde a gente tem tanto
questões ligadas à economia do
conhecimento quanto ligado a questões
sociais em que a gente precisa entender
melhor como a 11 assim a matéria
funciona questões de meio ambiente com
ações de solo questões de nutrição para
concluir essa história que eu vim aqui
contar pra vocês sobre o projeto mais
bem sucedido da acim
o brasileiro que começou há mais de 30
anos atrás e que teve um impacto enorme
não somente na ciência de alto impacto
mas na formação de recursos humanos
principalmente em alta tecnologia está
tendo a inovação está posicionando o
país hoje é no cenário internacional
hoje esse é um equipamento que é
respeitado no mundo inteiro e levando é
o nome do brasil
não é que não há algo de grande porte
como esse aqui obrigado a vocês pela
fifa
[Aplausos]